it's only willing to be with the
discomfort that any change happens you
don't have to do heaps just a little bit
I think the magic number's like four
percent or something it's just a little
bit but then you make the discomfort a
little bit harder if I ran away from
everything that scared me I'd live my
life on the head of a pen what does that
give me it gives me no options but if
I'm willing to be with the discomfort
suddenly I've got possibility this is
awful I wonder what I wonder what can
happen here because I've only ever known
what that looks like what could this be
like this isn't being with that
Curiosity and being with that
willingness to be uncomfortable that is
what has allowed me to actually have a
have a life now I can sleep at night